[Music]
ugh
what is up with this game at least the
vip stacks are on point these guys
just aren't true athletes like us these
champions could really do with some
shooting tips from yosemite fan
on second thought maybe not according to
a
lebron football fans think this is the
biggest game in the world bigger than
our game against the goon squad in july
no we uh we uh who are they kidding not
a chance
welcome to the space jam
[Music]
basketball camp is next weekend you got
amazing potential on the court
and i can help you get there that's not
what i want dad
you never let me do what i want to do
you never let me just
do me hold up wrong floor
fat will smith i gotta deal with this
what in the matrix hello
[Music]
welcome king james i am the king of this
domain
this is the server verse what you do to
my son where's dom
the only way you're getting your son
back is if you and i play a little
basketball
pete send this clown to the rejects
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this
i'm a cartoon what's up doc
i need to assemble an elite team to help
get my son back i know what you're
looking for
a dream team ma'am shoot the ball
let's try that again shall we
king james
[Music]
and get our son back
yikes
classic welcome to the space i'm going
old school on his butt
whoa welcome to the space jam
[Music]
you